i can see how skynet developed all
humanity was plundered so i come and the
t100
no
instagram influencer you have the accent
that suggests you might be one sir is
that correct
no you sound like you live out on the
west coast and uh do lots of photos of
you
with a product carefully placed in the
background and then at the bottom you
put hashtag ad and it's corrupting our
children and we need to stop
it
upsetting everyone else sir with your
height
um tall mean older brother instagram
influencer middle of the room it's your
chance
a kenducky derby horse with a broken leg
you've been waiting to say that all day
it's my turn kentucky darby
if you are in this wave would you like
first airplane flight
great thank you very much yes good yes
you sound like you actually know
all about it and are gonna sit there
picking holes in everything i say
so well technically it wasn't the wright
brothers actually it was a russian man
called so
mean older brother who is very tall um
the the first airplane flight uh
kentucky derby horse with a broken leg
and instagram influences
final suggestion is coming from this
segment what's it gonna be arnold
schwarzenegger and terminator
arnold schwarzenegger good that was not
a good impression but uh
that's the best i can do okay
this lovely people of the comedy seller
um is going to be
a little thing called a freestyle rap
that is a wrap made up on the spot based
entirely on suggestions not written
not prepared not rehearsed and yeah
don't worry it will not be anywhere as
atrociously embarrassingly toe-curlingly
bad as you're expecting a privately
educated middle class white british
boy to be uh let's have some fun
with this did someone just say oh my god
oh my god is right yes
oh my god urgently expressing what you
felt through your tooth there coming out
your lips on instagram
influencer you can see me post an ad you
can see me say you should buy this kid
get it every single day got paid a
pretty penny not dependent on the views
depending on the clicks everybody knows
you just look at the number
if it's the silly one high up like you
got 20.5 billion
you can make the cash you can make the
bank any of the generous kardashians got
to thank for this
overwhelming overriding sense of culture
being eroded
by these instagram vultures you can tell
i ain't got a lot of followers online i
don't mind about that guys i'm totally
fine i kick back
take a little shot to the head maybe
bourbon from kentucky breaking the leg
like a little horse i feel like such a
chop why cause i misjudged that height
of the jump i was running free
yeah i thought i'm in right step oh no i
broke like i'm drunk off mint juleps
tried to take
basically they're gonna kill you abort
you if you fall there turning you into
glue
horse racing in kentucky not a good
thing to do but they have no
choice they force into it you to be a
horse racer then pursue it
you can only do it if you want quality
is being so very small reach the height
of this guy's need
over there what's the deal with you
you'll be playing basketball like seven
foot two
your head reached the ceiling so you
have to lean you got pulled up by your
younger brother he was like you mean
just punch the little [ __ ]
call in the snitch i can't believe mom
raised you
such a [ __ ] the other [ __ ] call
you're a [ __ ] hench
my dick's as long as the marianas trench
probably
that's what people say you've got a lot
of hype probably
extra vertebrae coming out the back of
your spine
with sibling rivalry it's healthy and
fine
totally okay to do that feeling all
right in 1903 yeah they had the first
man flight
the wright brothers calling them wilbur
and orville a little bit of fabric from
the plane
thrill was put on the helicopter
currently on mars
the guy's [ __ ] nodding so all of
yours can look at him and say
that i'm getting it right it was
basically like a few seconds at the
height doesn't matter though
it's still a human achievement even
right now 100 years on i can't believe
it
technically 118 chris no one's had
enough
in their head all of them have pissed
but that's okay
we don't even mind we'd be making up the
words at the top of the line
i got so carried away by the quality of
the rap that i forgot the word that you
guys were shouting out last
so remind me arnold schwarzenegger yeah
there we go oh governor of california
running as republican but when he's in
the terminator oh was such a handsome
man
i need your claws and your motorcycle
i'm naked in the pool hall it's
certainly
vital coming in a sphere coming in an
orb
sending all the bad guys straight to the
ward in the first one
he was the evil he's the baddie but then
the second one
he was like i can see how skyled
developed
all humanity was plundered so i come and
the t100
no the t1000 that's the enemy
if you're drinking milk then i'm going
to set you free they put a knife through
the neck
that's a fact if you watch it there we
go a freestyle rap really some hot [ __ ]